Wait, but he's he's apologized. Yeah,
but the damage is done.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, bad day to be an Ethan fan, huh?
Dude, you're
I come up with the most outlandish
theories to just make Ethan not a bad
person. DON'T SAY IT OUT LOUD. SHUT THE
[__] UP. WHATEVER, MAN. You've fired
Okay, it it just keeps getting worse.
>> [music]
>> I read this last night and I I said,
"This seems like something someone might
want to address." So, this is quick
daily reminder that Ethan from H3 likely
who has his own children. It's a
comment. Funny. Everybody's laughing.
>> The the Destiny thing about Ethan and
his kids, that was one of those where I
was like, "Oh, man. I think I I stepped
too far out with this one." I'm sorry to
Ethan and Ethan's family for
uh
putting that nasty Destiny comment out
there. I felt like it was an okay thing
to do based on the point I was making,
but it gross shouldn't be spread like
that. So, let me tell you a little
story.
The second iDubbbz stopped talking about
us
happened to coincide
when I took into my um service some fine
Canadian um defamation lawyers that sent
a letter to Anisa
>> [snorts]
>> and uh Ian demanding
a retraction and a
halting of the defamatory statements
that I my children. He's apologized.
Yeah, but the damage is done. So, this
apology was not because I see people
[snorts]
they're taking this to mean that you
threatened them and that in response
he's apologizing. No, he's just doing
>> Oh, okay. They're desperate to prevent
litigation.
Got you. And they've preemptively
apologized out of pure um patheticness.
So, I've got the Papa Gut VOD here. Papa
Gut, if you remember last night, we were
reacting to Papa Gut, okay? And Papa
Gut, he was saying, essentially, that
like there's no way Ethan was suing
iDubbbz, right? He didn't believe it
when it was brought up. He was like
shocked that it was possibly happening.
And so now, this is him reacting to
Ethan Klein and his decision to sue
iDubbbz. If you guys haven't been paying
attention or following, this has been
kind of crazy today. Everybody's trying
to distance. Everybody's running away
from Ethan Klein. They can see him for
what he's been, so obviously, for the
past year, year and a half, 2 years?
Maybe for the past 5 years. This
disgusting, spineless, wretched
creature. And
that's who he is. He's probably been
this for a long time. It's really,
really unfortunate. But he's had a
sweeper, okay? He's had Nicholas Deorio
sweeping for him. Now, if you watched us
do the Keemstar reaction yesterday with
Papa Gut here, when we reacted when he
was reacting to the Keemstar video, he
swept on every single point. He was
actively attempting to sweep on every
single point. It was nuts. All right?
So, he is heavily invested in Ethan.
Lawyers that specialize in defamation
and
by the way,
I really don't think that's okay
thing to put out. Do you think anybody
actually looked at what iDubbbz said and
was like, "Oh, this is definitely not
what iDubbbz said. This is what Destiny
said. This is what iDubbbz highlighted."
and went like, "Oh, this is real." like
Some fine Canadian, um, defamation
lawyers had sent a letter to Anisa. He's
already losing it. He's already losing
it a little bit. Do you remember
>> Remember this guy? I am.
>> a retraction and a
halting
of
>> [clears throat]
>> of the defamatory statements, my my
children.
And the day after that,
>> Okay. the scorched [snorts] earth goon
was slaying.
Like Smaug, one There was only one scale
shown, and it was the threat of a
lawsuit.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> Cool. All right.
Cool, man. You know, here here's my
thing. Obviously, this lawsuit's petty.
It literally only exists to bully them.
Fine. But like, do you really think that
we were going to get in the mud with you
and be like, "Yeah, yeah, I love you.
Eat the cloud."
It's too [__] fallen. Every single
time that he's gotten in the mud, you've
all jumped in right behind him. So, he
probably figured you were all going to
do the same thing you guys have done
every single time before this.
Did you really think that just because
we jumped in the mud with you five more
five times in the recent past that we
would go in the sixth time with you? Did
you really think that?
Yeah, he thought that, obviously. One of
losers who have nothing left that would
be stupid and snarking you. We get it.
You know, you put some snark energy into
the atmosphere too. It's not pretend,
you know, you get you get pretty intense
sometimes. We get it, human skulls
happen, that's not good. CPS happen,
that's not good. But, you know, you just
like randomly decided when these people
are completely useless. Nobody believes
anything that they're saying and they're
signal boosting Destiny which you for
some reason aren't suing him. Nobody
Nobody thought it was like a real
threat. And you're like, "Oh, let me
bully this guy. Let me use my money to
go after this guy for no [snorts] other
reason to humiliate him. And then let me
announce it and be like, "Yeah,
everybody's going to think I'm so cool."
So, what what you could have done it and
then not highlighted it off. Yeah?
Oh my god. Oh my god. Wait, did he just
wake up? Did I just miss him waking up?
Did we just get a spark of sentience
from Papa Bowey? You get pretty intense
sometimes.
We get it, human skulls happen, that's
not good. CPS happen, that's not good.
But,
you know, you just like randomly decided
when these people are completely
useless. Nobody believes anything that
they're saying and they're signal
boosting Destiny which you for some
reason aren't suing him.
Nobody Nobody thought it was like a real
threat. And you're like, "Oh, let me
bully this guy. Let me use my money to
go after this guy
for no
And now, can we just be clear that there
is Hey, Papa, you dumb [__]
What is the difference between that and
him going after Kacey Tron?
Kacey Tron didn't do anything. Kacey
Tron did no harm. Kacey Tron got no
viewers, not really. Kacey Tron's not
doing She's not hurting anybody.
Right? I understand
that you should DMCA her. That you
should like make sure she can't do that
again. I could even understand saying
that Hey, I'm giving you a a notice if
you ever take my [__] again. But dude,
she didn't do any actual harm to you.
She didn't do any actual harm at all.
So, but guess what?
Somehow Casey Tron's like even more
reviled than these people. Everyone was
totally down for people to sue Casey
Tron.
And I might have even like maybe I could
have possibly understood or defended
somebody stomaching that one.
If his actual damages he got were
commensurate with the damages that he
faced that he suffered or if they had
anything to do with getting justice for
copyright at all.
They didn't.
The damages he sought, what he really
wanted was to humiliate somebody. That
showed you who he was as a person. And
everybody who is paying any amount of
attention
when he humiliated Casey Tron like that
for things totally outside of copyright,
apologize for all of this.
Say you like [__] up. Say Hassan
wouldn't give you money.
Talk about Hassan.
Right? When he did that, he showed who
he was. He is a petty, spiteful, tiny,
spineless, litigious
Yeah.
And you you were riding with this guy.
You totally you totally backed that.
You're totally psyched about that. And
now you're like, oh, this guy like might
be a mean, psychotic, like a totally
spineless, litigious loser.
Ethan, why are you acting the way they
said you were?
The way every the way all these people
said you were after you sued Casey and
made her do that hostage apology?
Why are you acting like that still?
Dude, he just shows you every step of
the way who he is and these people will
not pay attention. Well, I guess Papa
Goos is paying attention now,
thankfully. all other reason to
humiliate him. And then let me announce
it and I'm like, yeah, everybody's going
to think I'm so cool. So, what what you
could have done it and then not
highlighted it offline.
>> [snorts]
>> You know what I mean? Like that could
have been like a step you could have
done.
But I don't know, man. Who cares? Cool,
man.
Like great stuff, you know what I
>> [laughter]
>> You know what I mean? It's like, wow,
great. That's why I'm just not reveling
in this announcement. It's like,
cool, dude. I I know. Like iDubbbz has
has fallen. They're just kicking him
down like a dog. Like I don't okay, you
know, [gasps] like
it's like
Don't forget Casey takes care of her
sick mother while Ethan has a cut
throat. I thought it was her dad that
was sick. But regardless, I do know she
takes care of like a a parent who's got
like a disability.
Yes.
The only real asset she's got or one of
the only real assets she's got is her
home. I think she's got a bar or
something, too. But it's like her home.
And that's what was on the That was By
the way, that was why she was settling.
She was never ever going to go to that
case, even if she had a case. She's
never going to go Sorry, even if she had
a case, she was never going to go and
risk going to trial and getting
statutory damages that makes her lose
her house. It just wasn't worth it,
right? Like she would have You could
have asked her to say anything, she
would have said it.
It just It makes me It makes me feel
sick. It makes my stomach turn to watch
some like
moral black hole like Ethan Klein
get leverage over somebody and then just
watch him apply it publicly in a way
that he's just like clearly
getting off to.
Like he's just clearly filled with glee
watching this person under like with a
gun to their head saying all the things
he wants to say. He had hold the gun to
this person's head and make her dance
like a puppet. Very sick. Very ill.
Okay, okay, cool, man.
Right. It's not because they're
principled. Uh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not principled.
>> because he's above it. Okay. In fact,
they're hurting bad. Okay.
Look at him. His His
fallen off so hard. So true, dude.
>> It's crazy how hard it's fallen off.
Yep.
It was literally the day he stopped
talking about it, right? And then like
how would you How would you even win the
defamation lawsuit if they're so fallen
off?
Wouldn't that be an auto loss? Like you
have to know that, which means that the
lawsuit like announcement is just a way
to be like It's not an auto loss. No.
Even if it costs him a bunch of money,
they'll have to hire lawyers. What do
you mean it's an auto loss?
He just gets to stress their finances.
That's the goal, to torture them.
Because he is a like honestly like
bordering on evil
fantastic [__] okay?
He like that's just it. That's it.
That's what this stream was. Was him
just like basically waving a huge flag
at everybody. Look, I'm like I'm like
actually going towards evil. I have no
morals left. I am a total I am a total
reprobate. I'm a total piece of [__]
Like haha I would you know I
like you can't you can't go toe-to-toe
with me.
So you have to do what I want you to do.
This makes this is going to make people
look at all the other lawsuits but like
look back at them and go like mm.
You know, whatever good charity you had
earned, this is going to make it look
bad. Ironically, the most good charity
you got was from my disliking of
horrible hippies against you and it was
so bad it backfired.
So, you know. He doesn't talk about the
snark anymore.
He doesn't talk about me anymore.
And [clears throat] um they're by the
way desperately
unfor- This this is the ult- He can't
talk about you? it, right? He doesn't
talk about the snark anymore.
fallen off so hard.
It's crazy how hard it's fallen off.
It was literally the day he stopped
talking about it, right? He doesn't talk
about the snark anymore.
He doesn't talk about me anymore. Are
you saying he doesn't talk about that
anymore because of the lawsuit or he
just doesn't talk about it as much
anymore cuz it's not Is that what you
mean?
And um they're by the way desperately
unfor- This this is the ultimate irony
and I love this. Okay.
America, love America. Oh, cool. Me,
too.
>> [clears throat]
>> If he lived in California, I wouldn't
even
bother threatening to sue. Now, I think
this when Ethan's talking about this for
California, I think Ethan is saying
he knows that he's getting slapped down.
He's getting an anti-slap. Like and the
anti-slap [__] is going to be like
perfect. It's going to work perfectly
against him. Like I think he knows he's
got no shot against Noah Samson.
That's what that tells me when he's
like, "I wouldn't even bother if he was
in California." Huh?
Why?
I I'm pretty sure he's done in the No
Nonsense thing. I think him complaining
about anti-SLAPP in California, oof.
Ooh.
Dude, I think he knows. Because of
because in our great state
we have anti-SLAPP laws
that make it extraordinarily difficult
to sue
>> [snorts]
>> um public figures for defamation and
we have this extra
I know this isn't exactly an option for
the Keemstar video per se, but I think
the vid is going to be an all-timer
because it's making the sweepers have to
make moves they would have never made.
Well, the funny thing is the funny thing
is is
I don't think it's going to work. I
think
I understand
the move they need to make is like a mea
culpa.
That's the move. That's the only move.
You need to talk about what you did and
why and be honest about it.
That's the only move. Anything other
than a mea culpa, anything other than
admitting wrongdoing, admitting how you
[__] over other people in the process,
like everything that was wrong, right?
That's what you need to do. It's the
only way out. It's going to dog you for
a long time.
Although this is actually pretty good
that he's criticizing, but like I I like
that he's criticizing, but it's you have
to do a deeper analysis. The fact that
he hasn't shut Castlevania off might be
proof and like all the proof I need to
say Papa is not rehabilitated, okay?
This is rough. stream appreciation for
for free speech in the First Amendment.
Now, let me tell you something. This
doesn't make you look good. This makes
you look even more petty.
Wait, Top Bronson? That's a fantastic
question.
How does anti-SLAPP make it harder?
It doesn't. It actually doesn't at all.
The only thing anti-SLAPP does is make
it harder
to use your wealth to penalize people
when you don't have a case.
Isn't that so telling, actually?
That anti-SLAPP laws don't make it
harder to prosecute defamation. All they
make it harder to do is to file
vexatious litigation,
vexatious legal claims, to harm other
people.
It really sucks, but I would never have
done this in California, cuz I couldn't
use my wealth my wealth to bully these
people in California. It never would
have worked. Oh my god.
Everything he says just just betrays a
deeper rot within his soul, doesn't it?
Disgusting.
>> Ian, he hates America.
He wants to [clears throat] get as far
away as possible. He thinks this place
sucks. So, he moved to the to the
northern wall and pledged to the Night's
Watch. Okay. But Edmonton's not that
bad, man. Come on, dog.
Edmonton's not that bad. They got a nice
downtown area. What the [__]
Bro, even it's like an optic nightmare,
because like first of all, if you really
appreciate freedom of speech, then you
wouldn't be suing. No, he is a The
answer is not that he's an optic
nightmare, not that he's a deeply good
person who's just flawed, and maybe he
looks a little bit bad. No, he's a
deeply sh
person. He is a bad person. He is a bad
human being. No, it is not just bad
optics. He is a piece of [__] This
isn't itself a sweep. "It's really bad
optics, man. I don't think this looks
very good." is translated is "Dude,
Ethan, I want to like support you no
matter what, so I get free Teddy Fresh
merch, but like this looks really bad,
man. Like you're doing [__] that I would
look bad if I took your side, and that
makes me sad. Please don't think Please
just do things that are bad, but that I
could sweep for. If you keep it in that
range, that'd be better. Please? Please?
I mean, like but second of all, you know
people are just going to be like, "Oh,
he's doing like I love America thing."
They're going to associate you with the
right. They're going to say like, "Well,
he's not refusing to talk about like
real threats like Asmongold." and [__]
But he'll talk about I don't know. So,
so they're going to say they're going to
start saying that you're going to have
more information to say that you're
Yeah, oh, trust me. I'm very much
keeping track of the fact that when
Ethan had the opportunity to go after
somebody who's actually harmful and
actually harmful human human being in
the copyright cases, he could have gone
after Asmongold. His reaction is far
less transformative than Denims and he's
a total piece of sh
But he went after Denims over petty
personal grievance. In this case, for
defamation, he could go after Destiny,
the person who actually made the
statement, a total piece of sh
a a reprobate, human filth. But instead,
he's going to go after iDubbz over petty
personal
I don't know, fights, squabbles.
It's such Man, he's such a bad human
being, Ethan Klein. He's a sh person.
You consider that Hasan is bad. I do not
consider that. Wow. You're It's almost
like we should let
let Hasan stop dictating what we do and
don't do.
Like just in in general, right?
It's almost like if I'm If I have a
problem with you or something you've
done and you start talking about Hasan,
you should shut the [__] up. going
farther and farther right in your
right-wing chud posting.
Like now you're just like giving
ammunition to Hasan's audience to call
you like a right-wing weird chud.
You even made like a weird anti-feminist
comment before. Again, if I'm being
charitable, the the anti-feminist
comment was [laughter] I'm assuming you
think that they're virtue signaling
feminism.
But you're not exactly helping yourself
there, bud.
Like what is going on here? Dude, how
can you say How can Papa Gut Listen, I'm
It's hard for me to pay attention to
this guy. I'll be real.
But
was it not 5 minutes ago where he was
basically saying like, "Man, it seems
like you're just being mean. Like you're
kicking this guy like he's a homeless
guy. You're just kicking him in the
face." Like he's describing all of the
things He's basically describing Joffrey
from Game of Thrones. He's describing
somebody who's like bordering on evil,
who's right at the border of evil.
And then he's like, "Man, this is a real
optics nightmare, man. How do you do
that? How do you You're giving ammo.
You're get You're going to let these
people make you look bad, Ethan. It's
actually the same as CPS as the Oh, it's
the same as everything from before,
right? No, Ethan just looks bad when you
don't pay attention. But actually, like
it totally makes sense when you know
about CPS and the skulls and the Nazi
sword. Ethan looks really bad here.
And I wish he
He's not bad. He's not bad. He's not
bad. He just looks bad. He's not bad. He
just looks bad.
Uh but let me tell you something about
uh Canada.
>> [snorts]
>> The north.
The anti-slap laws wouldn't apply.
Destiny admitted that the that the
statement was made with malice. So, I
mean that he'd have a valid suit against
iDubbz.
Or would that only be in
No, iDubbz didn't make the statement. He
said somebody should address this. And
then he said, "I don't agree with the
statement." So, iDubbz didn't make the
statement and then say, "Well, I only
made the statement cuz I hate Ethan
Klein." iDubbz didn't make the
statement. He showed the statement, said
somebody should address this, and then
later it said, "I don't agree with that
statement at all. I just think someone
should address it cuz it's gross." I
don't think there's any way to interpret
that as defamation, to be honest with
you. Would that only be in reference to
like if you went after Destiny?
Certainly, that's not a way to You I
don't see how you could possibly sue
somebody for defamation over that after
they take it down and apologize after a
cease and desist. In that case, I think
there's no way. Oh, are you saying that
like the reason he's not going after
Destiny? Oh, wait a minute. Wait, can
you Can you confirm Mr. Ryan Beard, can
you confirm Destiny said that? Cuz if
Destiny did explicitly say that um he
said it with actual malice. Destiny said
it. And then he I believe he said this
person called me a So, I'm calling them
a
I think so. I see. Is that what you're
trying to say? Or am I just like
misinterpreting
everything? I wish I had the chat.
>> Defamation laws ain't quite the same up
there.
And when [laughter and snorts] I spoke
to an attor- Does that make sense? I
don't know if that makes sense. I don't
know like I don't really know the law.
Like maybe that's a theory. They're
like, "Yeah, no, this
This is quite bad.
This [snorts] is definitely actionable
here in Canada. In America
in California
you could say that.
Could have said that.
But in Canada Why do you think we do our
show here? Exactly.
>> [laughter]
>> Exactly. Do you think I could do the
show in Edmonton?
I'd be ruined.
Is this malicious? Because everything
has to tie back to me and Hasan has had
a lot of success in trying to tie people
back to me. Like I said, I think what
this is why I call Ethan all the time
just kids or whatever is because Ethan
gave in cuz he's a spineless hack to
this type of attack where he's like,
"No, I'm not like Destiny. Destiny
doesn't get me talking boy." I think
I've I think I seriously think me and
Ethan have traded two messages. I think
I've gotten one message from Ethan in my
entire I'd say my lifetime.
In addition to the the admission that he
knew he wasn't a
in DMs or in sorry, DG chat, I'd say so,
yeah.
>> that Twitter convo convo. It was like
two messages back and forth about the I
never remember. This is right after the
Israel
uh war thing. But he's like, "Hasan is
convinced." Or maybe he's not actually
convinced. Maybe he just knows that this
is a good tactic. That if you try to
rope people in with me enough,
eventually you can get them to like
start seeing the same hallucinations
that Hasan sees. Um yeah, so that's
yeah. Because
What was the
There was some drama that came up with
Hasan. I wish I could remember what this
was. I don't I think I feel like his
community or he might have tried to Like
even here, this is 2 months ago. More
stable. Still like schizophrenic, but
it's like slightly more stable at least.
>> for, but I was like driving when it
broke. I didn't cover any of it
initially. And he was trying to I think
he was trying to pin it on me. I'm
trying to remember what the drama was
though. It was like a a couple months
ago. Okay. Anyway, whatever. That I mean
that to me, he's saying he didn't call
him cuz he thought he was a called him
cuz
he abandoned me. Ethan abandoned me.
That's why I called him a
just kids is what Destiny just said.
I found me a Canadian lawyer who's
pretty gung ho about suing you.
I guess cuz he would like money. He's a
lawyer now.
And I might just do that.
>> [laughter]
>> And you know, he's grow Well, if he's
doing this, wouldn't that be mean that
you couldn't do that if if he
I believe but he's he's apologized.
Yeah, but the damage is done.
His apology was not
because [snorts] I see people
Dude, you got to They're taking this to
mean that you threatened them. No. And
he in response he's apologizing. No,
he's just doing
>> Oh, okay. Oh my god.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, bad day to be Ethan fan, huh?
Dude, you're
Whatever, man. You've I find okay. It it
just keeps getting worse.
It just keeps getting worse. Any any
theory that could be concocted that
makes Ethan look o
Dude, dude, you're not supposed to think
about the world this way. I come up with
the most outlandish theories to make
Ethan not a BAD PERSON. DON'T SAY IT OUT
LOUD. SHUT THE [__] UP. IT'S GOOD AS
POSSIBLE. It dies instantly. Like he
just said something else that just makes
his worse. Dude, Ethan Klein is
operating in extra-dimensional space
cutting off every escape. Here's a way
Here's a way that I possibly with with
strength there I can possibly make Ethan
Klein seem not like a monster. Oh, he
cut that off.
How do I DO IT? HOW DO I DO IT?
>> [laughter]
>> Uh
Yeah, I Dubs apologized and I'm still
I'm still doing it. Okay, cool.
>> [snorts]
>> All right, great, man. Uh Okay, very
litigious. Okay.
>> seems like you're definitely a way It
seems like a definite a definite
productive usage of your time. They're
desperate to prevent litigation.
Got you. And they've preemptively
apologized out of pure um patheticness.
But you know,
in my opinion because we there's no
agreement.
All right. You just want to go, "I'm so
sorry. Please, my principles."
>> Don't just be sorry.
>> Think for Exactly. Exactly.
Thank you, Christopher. Okay.
>> [__] legend. Christian.
>> Christian. Not Christopher. We're on
CLOSER TERMS.
>> OH, GOOD for you. So, uh So,
>> everything I need. I might Yeah, so the
defamation's already happened. We sent
them a letter saying like, "Hey, you got
to stop cuz you're the damages are just
mounting up." And they stopped
desperately stopped, right?
And they got a lawyer.
They They desperately stopped.
>> And now we're just I don't want
[clears throat] to give away the details
of our settlement because I'm I am
I'm way above that.
>> Oh god, it gets It gets so much worse. I
forgot that like after he drops the
lawsuit, it gets so much worse when he
gets asked questions. And then Dan Dan
is clearly annoyed with him, right?
Dan is like obviously upset with him
here.
Dude. Yeah. Yeah, Dan is actually upset
with Ethan here. So, when Ethan's like,
"Oh, I'm I'm I'm like I would never give
away the details of the settlement."
Dan's like, "So, you mean you're not
allowed to." He's just like making it
very clear that you're not being noble.
You're You're a piece of [__] right now.
Right, Dan? I'm Here, hold on. I'm way
above that. Right, Dan? Dude, that's
still the weirdest moment to me. I'm
just going to watch that again.
Now we're They stopped desperately
stopped, right?
>> here. And they got a lawyer.
And now we're just I don't want
[clears throat] to give away the details
of our settlement because I'm I am
I'm way above that. Right, Dan? Oh, papa
got pauses. PAPA GOT PAUSES with how
awful THAT IS. PAPA GOT CAN'T MAKE IT.
I'M WAY above that.
Right, Dan? You're above giving details
of the settlement?
>> I res- You've You've You've lost Dan.
You've completely lost Dan.
>> [laughter]
>> Dan's not even ON YOUR SIDE.
DUDE, you can't sweep this. It's
unsweepable. IT'S UNSWEEPABLE. There is
no broom strong enough. WHERE IS AUGIE?
Where is Augie? Augie's the only one who
can do it. I don't think Augie wants to.
I If If anybody could, it might be
Augie, but I don't know if anybody even
wants to try, man. It's so over. If I
was If I was Ethan, I would on
ironically I would operate my life based
on like Dan. Dan would be my He's my
He's my Geppetto. Or no, he's the He's
the cricket.
Right?
Is that what it is? Which one is the
cricket? Jiminy Cricket. Jiminy Cricket.
Jiminy?
>> [laughter]
>> All right. August got that make me look
good. August make me look really good,
please. It seems like Dan is just like
not on your vibe, bud. He does not seem
to be thrilled. Is this just like
crashing [clears throat] and burning any
credible Why is it that every time I
watch the show Dan seems to be not on
the vibe?
Well, he has left. respect the Canadian
legal system with the utmost care and
respect.
>> I see.
And you're not supposed to share any
details is what
>> never I would never The Crown would
never You usually share everything, so
that doesn't sound right at all.
>> the Crown.
Okay. [snorts] So, it sounds like
because you're not allowed to.
Not allowed to is one thing, but I just
respect the Crown.
>> Okay. Got it.
I will say that though. So awkward.
It's so awkward, man.
>> to do it, right? Because the damages,
right? To my reputation. There's no
damages to his reputation. Holy dude,
this is so stupid.
Right?
>> This is so dumb. Jesus Christ. Our um
are terrible. I feel terribly damaged.
Um and there's actually [clears throat]
such a crazy funny thing about the
Canadian thing too, cuz he moved to
Canada. I learned [laughter]
you can't even crowd fund Woah woah
woah.
>> for lawsuits. What?
And you can't you
>> Why?
So, I I'm not sure the exact law, but if
he did crowd fund, they'd have to
basically ID
and verify the identity of every single
person that gives money.
Is he
I I
ironically didn't think I had no idea
about that. Is that true? No idea.
Like every [clears throat] single time
he talks I'm like wow, like everything
really just leads to be like you really
just want to like
humiliate this I I think it's a
massively disproportionate thing. I
mean, this is ridiculous.
Is anybody on this guy's side here?
>> [clears throat]
>> Let's be real and fix everything. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying. Absolutely.
[__] I dubs. He's slowly getting
there, right? He's He's stopped He's
like hardening the language as it goes
along, and it's because
Dan's the only person with something
like It's not quite a spine, but there's
only Dan's the only one with something
there a little bit, and it That's what
makes Ethan look bad. When everybody
stops clapping along, and somebody just
goes, "Bro, what the [__] happening?
What Like what are you doing?" Then the
people watching can see a little bit a
little bit that like, "Oh, this actually
is bad." And you can tell as soon as
that Dan moment came,
Papa Goey, he started to flip a little
bit, right? It's still not Oh, this
guy's like a total piece of [__] He's
totally reprehensible. He's a He's like
It should It should be that based on
what he's describing for behaviors.
Yeah, it's a little It's still too soft,
but he's got to like
>> I unironically didn't think that it
could get worse. Like I didn't think it
could get more dumb and petty.
>> [clears throat]
>> Dumb and petty
is not enough. Like every single time he
talks, I'm like, "Wow." Like everything
really just leads to be like, "You
really just want to like
humiliate this person." I I think it's a
massively disproportionate thing. I
mean, this is [__] ridiculous. When
you consistently look to hurt
in a massively disproportionate fashion,
when you consistently look to hurt,
humiliate, denigrate your opposition.
What do we call that, class? Is anybody
on this guy's side here?
>> [clears throat]
>> Let's be real and fix everything. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying. Absolutely. I
dubs definitely fixed his reputation
with that hippies. I even said that
before.
This just makes him look this This is
stupid, dude. This is so [__] dumb.
This is so stupid, bro.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> Oh my god, bro.
>> [sighs]
>> Jesus Christ. You know what? I guess
it's just [__] black and white.
>> I know what you mean, but
>> you got me feeling bad for [__] I
dubs.
>> out. Chill. So,
cool stuff, man.
Like he can't even crowdfund for it to
try to like do something. Bro, this is
This really is This really is giving
oppressive millionaire
vibes, [laughter] dude.
Vibes? NO, IT ISN'T A IT isn't a
It is an oppressive billionaire. You
stupid
That's literally what it is.
That's that you are a he is an
oppressive millionaire. He is a
millionaire silencing free speech of
people who are critical of him or like
Was it even critical? DUDE, YOU GET YOU
SUING A DRAGON DOING A FUNNY VOICE. Oh
my god, what is this?
Like you're suing a
dude doing a burnt peanut but with a
dragon doing a goofy ass voice
putting a screenshot of what somebody
else said on the screen. Dude, give your
give your head a shake. That's what it's
giving right now.
That's what it's giving right now.
Uh I don't know.
You know, this is this is a it's giving
giving some interesting vibes, dude.
Okay. So, it's like
>> Yeah, why is Destiny off scot-free,
dude? What the [__] going on with
that? Basically virtually impossible it
would be to, you know, do something like
that on GoFundMe. Okay. So, he they're
not even capable of crowdfunding for
this. The fact that he they moved to the
cabin.
>> they have to do that?
iDubbbz is a really successful YouTuber.
You're right.
>> got a lot of money, right? Dan, Dan, I
know that you're just trying to support
your Ethan Klein right here, but I can
tell with the your voice that you were
unthrilled.
>> [laughter]
>> I thought I thought Papa Gut was going
to give him a talking to for sweeping
there. I thought Papa Gut was going to
was going to step in and go, "Dan,
I know you want to support Ethan, but
it's too much now." Like
to the [laughter] maximum degree.
So, [clears throat]
stop pretending. It's occurring putting
his hand on Hitler's shoulder going,
"Dan, Hitler is a one Jew too far now.
It's one Jew too far." pretending.
Stop pretending, dude. Cuz we know it.
Stop enabling your friend. Thanks for $2
from [__] Sharky Production. Ethan is
so lame for this. Why not go for
Destiny? I think it's just to go after
iDubbbz.
Destiny
>> you're right. I I assume a lot of people
would want to support them. That's all.
In fact, I didn't I hear that uh
that they never have to work another day
in their life?
>> Anisa said that yeah, recently. Let's
give it up for the
>> they're pretty well
So [cough] true. Right. So true, dude.
So, [snorts]
Okay. I think I'm going to speed up
here.
Yeah, no problem. This is about Look,
this is about protecting my family and
my reputation, you know? And while I
understand one of the reasons why he's
doing this now, he wants to get like a
bunch of public statements up there
about how his whole family is
emotionally distressed and all this
stuff. So, that's what he brings into
the lawsuit. So, he's saying publicly
how his whole family and my reputation
and my reputation is harmed, blah blah
blah.
He's just doing this uh he's doing this
for the lawsuit. He's making this
episode that in my opinion is harming
his credibility, especially to people
who are more on his side, uh just so
that he can have more information in the
lawsuit to go after iDubbbz.
That's what this is. That's That's
exactly It's The wild thing to me is how
people are trying to make this
significantly different from other
behavior.
It's not.
It's just not.
It's literally not even what I To be
honest,
I think it would still be made and as
much as I do think it would be funny and
I would laugh about it and I
I would still say it makes Ethan Klein
look worse if he sued Destiny. Like, I
don't necessarily I think basically
suing somebody for like for talking some
[__]
Right? In a way that's obviously not
real.
I think that's made.
Now, I personally think Destiny deserves
all possible like legal harm done to
him, but it would still be a vexatious
lawsuit, yeah.
And I Like I
I would probably go Yeah, I would think
less of Ethan if he did it.
I probably would have a hard time,
really, you know, selling the farm to
to champion Destiny's cause, but I would
still say, "Yeah, it's bad. I don't want
him to do that. He shouldn't do that."
Right? And Ethan's been engaging in this
kind of vexatious litigation for a while
now. And I do The only real difference
here is that it's for somebody else's
words on the screen.
But realistically, Noah Samson, I think,
is actually
I think there's an argument that Noah
Samson defamed Ethan less than iDubbbz
has.
I'm not even joking when I say that. I
think Noah Samson's speech is totally
ironclad protected, and he's still being
sued. I think Idubbbz actually was worse
in terms of defamation.
And nobody Nobody stands up for Noah
Samson cuz they hate him.
I mean, I guess they don't like Idubbbz
either, but
>> what this is cuz he's like, "Oh, my
reputation."
Cuz he has to play it up like it was
like a real damaging thing to his
reputation, or else people would be or
else like the courts would be like, "Oh,
this is obviously not true. You
obviously don't care as much as you're
letting on to or pretending to care."
The fact that he moved to Canada was was
a 5D chess play um
uh against himself. Right. I mean,
listen, if Idubbbz is the Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on.
I know The only way Idubbbz is for you
to move to Canada
or kill yourself. Okay? This is the only
way.
This is the only way, Idubbbz. You have
to understand.
There are greater goals. There are
greater goals at play, Idubbbz. You have
to go to Canada
and it will result in your destruction,
but know
that your destruction will also lead to
the destruction of Ethan Klein.
Know that moving to Canada, you will be
our martyr, Idubbbz. You will be our
martyr. You will have to go down,
but know that you will drag Ethan Klein
to hell with you. And you
will be redeemed in the end. You will
get your 40 virgins
in heaven
at the highest level of paradise.
Thank you so much, Idubbbz, for your
sacri- YOU
YOUR MARTYRDOM will not be forgotten.
Thank you, Idubbbz, for moving to Canada
and sacrificing yourself for all of us.
Thank you. Thank you.
>> [laughter]
>> His His name was Ian Show me your hole.
My god, yes.
Very good. So, I'm very happy he moved
to Canada. I'm glad to know that we have
the best and brightest protecting us in
the north.
Winter's coming.
Damn. I'm a woke dragon.
And I wish you guys the I'm a woke
dragon. Okay. the best. Mhm. I really
do. Okay. I really really do. I So, why
you know,
I didn't follow all this. What what what
[laughter] Dan's so clearly upset.
The quote was a Destiny quote. Right.
But the thing is, Destiny made it clear
he didn't believe it.
Did he make that clear? I thought he
made it clear that he did believe it.
No, he made it clear that he said it. He
He made it clear that he didn't believe
it later, but he made it clear that he
was saying it to [__] with Ethan. Jesus
Christ, dude.
Internet versus. The Oreo stream is
definitely content. Okay.
>> Drama.
Is there a [__] Maybe I mean maybe I'm
wrong. Is there like a
Dude, the Internet versus is like a
who's who
of brave patriots, okay? The Internet
versus of this this episode, it's like
brave patriots only, all right?
>> I guess I don't know. He did it with
malice.
What that mean Destiny did with malice?
And he insisted he didn't believe it
either.
I'm so I mean I understand that might
have been sarcastic, but that doesn't
really matter.
Ian didn't make the statement. Ian
looked at a statement and he said, "I
don't know what this is, but someone
should address it."
And then a little bit later he goes,
"And I don't even believe that. I think
it's like really gross to imply that.
And I think Ethan should address it cuz
it's really gross to imply that." He's
never implying he believes that at any
point. Destiny does imply he believes
that at certain points.
>> He's being clearly sarcastic here when
he talks about his motivations for it.
Like, "Oh, it hurt my reputation." What?
He was just doing it to be an
But that's
So he's saying Somebody's saying, "Oh,
when Ethan says it hurt my reputation,
he's being sarcastic?"
I don't think so. That would be really
bad for a lawsuit, no?
>> he do it? Did this make
Yeah, I don't think [clears throat] Ian
ever has actually believed it. He was
just doing it to be an
What's the difference?
What? Can he really not understand the
difference between
laughing at somebody else talking [__]
to Ethan Klein,
defaming Ethan Klein, and going, "I
don't think that's cool. Uh D shouldn't
do that." And Ethan going And Destiny
going, "Ethan Klein's a pedophile. He
hurts kids." And then going, "Yeah, I
said that cuz he called me a too."
You're You're implying you Well, one, he
says he later does admit that he didn't
think that, but he also clarifies that
he said it to cause harm to Ethan
because he knew Ethan. He was mad at
Ethan.